- All right, Stephen
Stephen, where'd you grow up?
Where you from originally?
- I grew up over
in the Alhambra area,
not too far from here.
- Suburb of L.A.?
- Yeah.
- And, tell me about your
childhood, you grow up
with both your parents?
- No,
early divorce,
I was like five years old or so.
- Your parents split up?
- Yeah, I was with my dad
for most of my childhood
and that was really cool,
then I went over to my
mom for a little bit.
And then she moved so now I'm
actually out here on my own.
- How long you been out here on Skid Row?
- About two and a half, three years maybe.
I try not to
hang out here as much as I can,
'cause I know it's crazy and dangerous.
- Yeah, it is.
- I'd like to have a life
where it's progressing,
but I know drugs,
it's like you can't move too far.
- How was your childhood?
- Fortunately it was good.
The divorce, I was young
enough where it, I didn't know
what relationships were
like so it didn't know.
It really didn't have an effect.
I still saw Mom and Dad,
they weren't together,
I just didn't see the relationship because
I was too young to understand
what a relationship was.
So, I mean, it was good.
My father was a good guy.
He took care of me a lot.
My mom was a good mother.
I don't have any siblings but it was cool.
It was fine.
- Then when you were on
your own, where'd you go?
Did you go to college?
- Well, I attempted that
but I was never really
into academics.
- Yeah
- That was at the same point in time where
I started using drugs so
that was the critical pivot.
Do I try to do the
academics and do that route
or I wasn't going to say drugs were going
to be a route of life
but that's kinda like
what took over and became life.
And, that's what ended up happening.
- What were the first drugs
you played around with?
- It was like marijuana and drinking
and then Vicodin pills
were very cool thing
to do at the time. You progress with those
and then sure enough injuries happen.
You get on pills again
and then they give you
a little stronger ones and
those things get harder to get.
And then you just kinda jump
over to opiates or heroin.
- Prescription runs out and you
- Yeah, exactly, prescription goes
and street price is expensive.
Doctors won't give you anything.
- That's a common way.
People get addicted.
- Yeah
- And, so where are you staying now?
- I used to have a tent around here.
I've been on the train quite a bit though.
I want to get out of the area.
I really do.
So I tell myself to
get on the train to go.
I get on it and then I go
then I realize oh fuck,
I'm going to be sick.
- Yeah
- So I gotta come back.
- You gotta come back to get your heroin.
- Yeah
- What do you do for money now?
- It was boosting.
I don't do that anymore.
So now I just try to find little stores
and I try to sweep their parking lot
or do some windows, something.
Random, different stores I know.
They'll help out, like
20 bucks here and there.
- Nice
- Yeah
- Something honest.
- I don't want to go to jail, man,
I don't, I don't
- Have you been in jail?
- Yeah, I'm tired of it dude.
I'm too old for it.
The time is not worth the
money you get for stealing.
It's stupid.
- Yeah
- I try and find the honest work.
I can find a job,
an actual job
paying job with a check and stuff
but residence,
The Refresh Spot's cool.
It keeps you clean, you
can shower and stuff
but sometimes it's so crowded that
you miss your showers there.
- For those who don't know,
there's a place called The Refresh Spot
down here where people
can take showers and
what else do you do over there?
- You can do laundry,
charge your phone if you have one.
Sometimes they give you referrals or
different other resources around the area.
- There's really resources
for everything and anything,
right?
- Yeah, there is down here
- Food, clothing, rehab, recovery, shoes.
The only thing they don't seem to give out
are tents, right?
- Time and time, some places do.
- Do they?
But, I notice with the
clothes and stuff like that
you have to hit 'em on a good day or
the place themselves are gonna take it and
give it to their residents there.
- Yeah
Did you ever have dreams
of doing something
in your life, or goals?
- A specific dream, like a career dream or
just like something
- No, no, no like goals.
I mean like did you
want to become a doctor
or a lawyer or anything like that.
- I mean every kid is like
oh I want to be a doctor
or I want to be a police
officer or something like that.
I did too, you know?
I did.
But I never followed through with it.
Right now,
I could say I'm still in that same place.
I have these goals.
I know what I want to do in a sense but
it's the first steps,
I don't know how to do it.
How do I go about getting
to those positions?
I know how to enroll in
school and you do that.
I know how to show up and be on time but
after that, where does it take me?
If I want to go to the
construction sites and
say "Hey, you guys hiring?",
"No, we're not right
now. Go to our website."
Do that and keep showing
up and it's still "no",
then I don't know what to do there.
I don't know how to expand that.
My networking skills aren't that great.
- And then, your drug is heroin?
- Yeah.
Sometimes crystal meth too.
- And being addicted to heroin or meth,
you can't really make it
through a full work day, right?
- No, well,
I can make it through a full work day
but it's making sure I have something
in the morning to start
that day is the issue.
Having enough money in
the morning to go to work.
After that it's fine.
Like say if I start a job,
it's gonna take two weeks
before I start getting
my first check so what am I going to do
the first two weeks?
I have to really try to make sure I don't
get in trouble by the law
or I have to make sure I have enough
to continue to go to work.
So it has to be really planned out.
And, out here, things never go
the way they're supposed to.
- Never
- Yeah
- If someone was to walk
you over to one of the
recovery programs here and just like
dropped you off and
say "stick with it" and
"follow through", "get
your life in order", and
"get out of this
neighborhood", and "get a job",
and "get your life together",
do you think that would work out?
- Yeah, I mean, I do and I don't.
I want that.
I want to be in recovery.
I want to be sober, I do.
But, I also want to have freedoms too.
I don't wanna have to be bound to
six seven groups a day,
which takes up all day and
they say you can't get a job until
you are six months into it.
Well shit.
I mean I know that's not
any kind of amount of time.
Six months is nothing looking at it.
But in that moment, sitting there,
you're like "damn, well,
I wanted to do that now."
And, it's just that whole
"I want it now" thing.
It cuts it off, blocks it out of the way.
- Yeah
- I would do it right now, I would,
I want to
I guess the uncertainty of the future too.
- Do you think some of this is just
your self-worth is being what it is,
it kinda just like puts
you in this situation
and you almost feel like somewhere,
subconsciously you deserve it?
That this is where you belong
or something like that?
- I used to think that way
I used to
It was like that for a
majority of my addiction.
It wasn't 'til recently that,
I want to say within the last
I think it was actually getting down here
they actually made me
feel I had more self-worth
because I actually saw
the rawness of this.
- Yeah
- And actually, it's
kinda messed up to say,
but it actually kinda
boosted my self-esteem almost.
- Yeah?
- But I know it's not for everyone.
It doesn't happen for everyone.
Who's to say it's gonna last too?
Who's to say it's gonna last?
- Yeah
This is the bottom of the barrel.
- Yeah and I know like some people say
they get down here,
they get off the bus and they never leave.
That's kinda so far what's
happened to me in a sense.
- The Greyhound Station is
right at the end of the,
you see it from here.
That's where people come
from all over the country
and get dropped off and
- Think they're gonna go
to the financial district
- (laughs) They go through (garbled).
- Yeah, they can't make it the half mile.
- They spend the rest of their lives here.
I hope you don't.
- No, I don't want that man, I don't.
- How old are you?
- 27
- Yeah
- Well Stephen, thank
you for talking to me and
- Yeah, no problem.
- good luck and I hope
you figure out a way to
climb out of this.
- Yeah,
I need to sit down and
really like thoroughly
just
think it through or just
find out how to go about it.
The resources are here, just use 'em.
That's what I gotta do just
fucking use them things.
- Yeah
- That's what it comes down to.
Half measures or whole steps.
- That's it.
- Yeah
- All right, well, thank
you for talking to me.
- Awesome brother
- Thank you man.
- Cool.